diskutiert wird macht mir
macht man schon Sorgen
da bin ich der Einzige was ich aber wo
genau ist die Elise Benachteiligung von
Frau aber immer sehr stark war das ist
mir eigentlich
auch schon wieder zurücksetzen genau
oder sogar aggressiv verhalten
ja
sexistische Witze gemacht
[Musik]
Emotion reagieren
sehr
wurde
ist stark
e Emotionen
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
geworden
Beschäftigung
ja
Familien
normalisieren
[Musik]
also im Prinzip
glücklicher
[Musik]
Karriere machen
und ja also BMW immer
die stanzieren und klar machen
argumentieren
[Musik]
nicht strukturelle Problem sondern
Problem
[Musik]
ja aus Maar der Sachen
wie
abschiebbar aber das ist mäßiger
anerkannt und Gesellschaft
wo man aber man
Verantwortung
übernehmen und ja vielleicht nicht so
feststellen
natürlich
riesig und da muss ich selber Gedanken
machen
es ist mehr so schlimm es wird aber
immer recht von der Benachteiligung von
Frau und
da bin ich der Einzige was ich alles
wo genau ist die Riesen Benachteiligung
von Frau
effektiv Gesellschaft
hat es zum Glück noch nicht so stark
müssen erfahre ich hau nicht ich habe
mich nicht
benachteiligt wird oder nicht
auf das Gerät
du automatisch mit deinem konfrontiert
okay dann muss sie machen
nachteiligungen wo du ausmalen
hey Rafael
ist grundsätzlich die Chance
und gefahren
verantwortlich sein
[Musik]
Podcast zum Thema Aktivismus und
Männlichkeiten
und bewusst Umgang mit ziemlich
cool
sicher für
Podcast
freudig freudig und optimistisch
im Gegensatz zu meinen
traditionellen Frage
was ist Verständnis verschlachtet
sich und rausmachen
aktiv
[Musik]
vom Online-Magazin Roland
passiert wie die Aufzeichnung vor dem
Podcast das so
Diskussionen
stattfindet auseinandersetzen
angesichts wie die ganze gender Thematik
im Moment mit der Medien
diskutiert wird machen wir machen wir
stimmt nicht nur positiv
aber zurück zu mir und der fragt wie
taxisch minimalkeit ist vor ca 2 Jahren
hat der Kollegin auf insta ihre Story
teilt von der Typ über stark macht das
Worte
für mich momentan
verhängige Frage
auf Instagram
[Applaus]
dass ich mit jeder Hand passiert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sondern ich
Vater so einfach eine
Arsch geschoben sondern es wird einfach
gleicher du Bestellvorgang
gearbeitet ernährt sie und Beschützer
und das braucht
aber eigentlich Platz schaffen
[Musik]
wieso hast du eigentlich
du hast noch mehr
ja ja
aus dem Markt und
aber irgendwo wo wir eine
jetzt in der Mutter aufgewachsen das
heißt mir ist die
Blick auf die Perspektive
Schweiz
[Musik]
beschäftigen hätte mir der Prozess
ausgelöst er persönlich entwickelt
genau